the beginning of 2022 has seen absolute
crazy uncertainty and chaos in financial
markets we have seen assets go up down
sideways and it seems like nobody knows
what's going on but now we are starting
to get a clearer picture all of the haze
is starting to fade away bitcoin is up
and stocks are down there's a complete
decoupling underway if we go ahead and
we start just by looking at the bitcoin
price what we can see is that bitcoin
was down significantly to start the year
it then traded sideways and has come
roaring back to the point where now
bitcoin is positive on 2022 year to date
if we then go ahead and take a look as
to why this may be occurring we've got a
quote here from the founder of nexo
where he says as we test the top of the
2022 trading range for the fifth time
this is another one of these bitcoin
moments when the narrative could swiftly
change and investors pile in propelling
the bitcoin price higher it might just
be time to awaken from the bitcoin
sideways slumber that's ben 2022 now of
course bitcoin doesn't operate just in
its own silo it is a financial asset
that trades alongside other financial
assets if we take a look at the equity
market what we see is that both the snp
and nasdaq are down the snp and nasdaq
both going down while bitcoin going up
year to date this is part of that
decoupling that is occurring we are
watching bitcoin outperform the equity
markets just like it did last year and
just like it's done for the last decade
or so now we have this other quote here
which goes ahead and explains from the
ceo of bitbull capital well market
participants are starting to get bullish
and the fear and greed index is at
neutral bitcoin bulls will want to see
the price consolidating above 46 000 for
further continuation the coming week is
also important as it marks the end of
the quarter and we could see increased
volatility after that now let's go take
a look at the fear and greed index what
we see is that right now the fear and
greed index is at 60 slightly into the
greedy part of this index if we look at
where it's historically been this is
quite a shift just yesterday it was at
49. last week and last month we were
down in the 20s and 30 on that index
there was lots and lots of fear
if you're an investor and you saw the
fear you saw the blood in the streets
and you were buying an asset that
continues to outperform over long
periods of time it's proven to be a
pretty good decision bitcoin is up
stocks are down that is a theme that
seems to be playing out over and over
and over again if you haven't already
learned about bitcoin now might be a
good time to start paying attention hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time